[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
frança 24 ya está conmigo en el estudio
rosa pérez más de un rosa bienvenida
buena mañana del jueves vamos a dedicar
esta revista de prensa a una
investigación del medio francés y mono
rosa reveló que el gas extraído por la
petrolera francesa total sirve de
carburante para los aviones de combate
rusos en ucrania
efectivamente buenos días raúl y esta
información esta investigación lo hemos
le da tanta importancia que la sitúa en
portada como vamos a ver a continuación
y de hecho algo que este periódico
francés hace a menudo cuando quiere
destacar eso una información y un
titular muy contundente es publicarlo
sin imagen o sin ilustración aquí detrás
lo estamos viendo blanco sobre azul con
la siguiente frase el gas de total
energía alimenta los bombardeos rusos en
ucrania dice particularmente cuando
desgrana un poco este titular el grupo
francés explota en siberia junto con el
ruso novatech un yacimiento de donde
extraen condensado de gas natural bien
condensado se transforma en queroseno
que recordemos es el combustible de los
aviones y este combustible este
queroseno que ha sido extraído digamos
de este condensado de gas natural de
este yacimiento que explota total sirve
de combustible a los aviones de combate
rusos que luchan en ucrania luego lemont
señala que al contrario que otras
grandes empresas energéticas total ha
permanecido en rusia no trabajando en
este caso en siberia a pesar digamos de
las sanciones que se han impuesto contra
rusia a raíz de su invasión de ucrania
pero es que recordemos que el gas está
exento de las restricciones que han
puesto la unión europea que sin embargo
se han afectado por ejemplo a otros
recursos fósiles como son el la petróleo
o el carbón bien y también señala que
total tiene en rusia el 20 por ciento de
su producción y de sus reservas rosa
vamos ahora a comentar algunos de estos
detalles de la investigación como lo
titulé el artículo como el gas de total
año que sirve para los aviones de
combate rusos de nuclear efectivamente
recordemos lo que decíamos que total se
esconde digamos o argumenta esta
excepción que tiene el gas ruso respecto
a las restricciones de otros de otras
materias primas no pero dice lo mont en
rusia total energía no sólo exporta gas
hacia europa como argumenta a menudo
para justificar su presencia en rusia
sino que como venimos diciendo las
explotaciones de yacimientos en siberia
en este caso sirven para funciones a que
sirven al final a los intereses
militares rusos particularmente hablamos
del gas natural del yacimiento de termo
cars toby en siberia como venimos
diciendo que está explotado por la
compañía ter neftegaz ternero este gas
es propiedad en un 49 por ciento de
total energía es de la francesa y en un
51 por ciento de la russa novatech rosa
pero digamos que la pregunta no de este
artículo me imagino que lo que se
basaron también para hacerlo cómo
llegaremos a identificar que estos
recursos naturales de este yacimiento se
usan para la guerra en ucrania lo hace
gracias a los datos recopilados por la
ong global witness obtenidos a través de
la base de datos financieras definitive
de la bolsa de londres y gracias a estos
datos lo mont rastrea que la cadena de
suministro que va desde el yacimiento de
termo cars to be al que nos referíamos
llega hasta las bases militares aéreas
de moxos kayak y manchego donde albergan
digamos flotas de aviones de combate
show con estos aviones de combate han
sido identificados en harkis y también
se les atribuye los ataques sobre
mariupol particularmente amnistía
internacional señala que estos aviones
que habían usado este combustible que ha
sido extraído en primera instancia de
este yacimiento operado por todo por
total bombardearon por ejemplo el teatro
de mariupol donde amnistía internacional
estimó que murieron unas 600 personas
entre ellas pues a decenas de personas
de población civil quien responde de la
empresa a estas acusaciones rosas pues
ha condenado públicamente la invasión y
señala que ellos al final
en voz ni voto a pesar de tener un 49
por ciento de esta compañía sobre las
ventas que se hace de este condensado de
gas natural ante esta situación le
pregunto la posición entonces de lemont
que dedica pues o editorial como lo
estamos viendo a este tema exactamente y
para resumir la voy a leer algunos
párrafos algunas líneas de este
editorial que recordemos es la posición
del periódico en este caso lo mont sobre
este tema dice es difícil encontrar un
producto más estratégico que el
carburante en una guerra al poseer parte
del yacimiento de termo cars toby de
donde se extrae carburante que sirve a
abastecer los aviones de combate rusos
usados en la guerra contra ucrania los
dirigentes de total se exponen a una
terrible acusación ayudar a moscú en la
agresión armada que desde hace seis
meses transforma una parte de europa en
zona de muerte y desolación y amenaza la
integridad de un estado soberano y
recuerda que en enero el total energy
sse tuvo que retirarse de mianmar tras
la revelación de lemont de que
contribuía a financiar la junta militar
dice del mismo modo nuestra información
de hoy cuestiona con gravedad el hecho
de que mantenga sus actividades en un
país que lleva a cabo guerra injusta en
el corazón de europa y acaba este
editorial diciendo que la pregunta
digamos el cuestionamiento no sólo va
dirigido al total energía sino también
al estado francés rosa como siempre
gracias por toda la información de la
revista de prensa del día de mañana
viernes por supuesto con más pasamos a
saludar a nuestro primer invitado al día